هل كنت أحد هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يطاردون
رمز qr حول شاشة التلفزيون أثناء
الوعاء الكبير حتى الركوع على ركبتيك
أو ربما مثل هذه الجدة البالغة من العمر 95 عامًا ،
فأنت تقول ما هذا
الذي فهمته ، لا ، أليس كذلك؟
لقد حصلت عليه أو ربما كنت في
حفلة سوبر بول مع الضيوف الذين قاموا
بجذر الشفرة أكثر من الكباش
أو البنغال
التي تم ضغطها حول الشاشة لمدة 60
ثانية ،
في إشارة إلى شاشة توقف دي في دي القديمة
التي أصبحت ميميًا حتى
انتهى بها الأمر  على المكتب ، يوجد هذا
المكعب على الشاشة ، وهو يرتد طوال
اليوم ويبدو أحيانًا أنه
يتجه مباشرة إلى زاوية
الشاشة وفي اللحظة الأخيرة يصطدم
بجدار ويقفز بعيدًا ولكن أين هو
والدو ولكن إعلان رمز الاستجابة السريعة هذا كان لـ
Coinbase لشركة تجارة العملات المشفرة
وإذا كان هاتفك قد التقط الرمز ، فمن
المفترض أن تحصل على عرض بقيمة
خمسة عشر دولارًا من عملة البيتكوين المجانية للتسجيل
ولكن الكثير من الأشخاص حصلوا على هذا بدلاً من ذلك ،
فنحن نواجه مشكلات في الاتصال بالآخرين
حصلت على صيانة مخططة قيد التقدم ،
وهو ما لم تخطط له Coinbase على ما يبدو
هو أن هذا
رأينا أكثر من 20 مليون زيارة إضافية على
صفحتنا المقصودة في دقيقة واحدة ، أدى هذا الحجم
إلى اختناق أنظمتنا مؤقتًا
لشخص آخر أثنى على العقل
الكبير للرجل الذي  جاء هذا الإعلان
ولكن أحد النقاد غرد بأن الشركة كان يجب
أن توفر تكلفة الإعلان البالغة 7 ملايين وأن
تنفقها على خوادمك في
الواقع تكلف 60 ثانية على
الأقل 13 مليونًا
ولكن من يحسب عندما
يهتف المعجبون بكود qr كما لو كان qb
يسجل a  هبوط
الجني معظم
cnn نيويورك